[Musique]
martin biron michel david michels urgent
et bonsoir au panel hier ceux qui
étaient avec nous à l'antenne on a dit
c'est sûr je pensais vous martine le dit
c'est sûr que demain monsieur legault va
commencer sa conférence de presse en
parlant de la situation en france
je vous le fait entendre quand on
regarde en france trente six mille
nouveaux collègues c'est cinq fois plus
que nous autres c'est presque dramatique
l'on n'a plus de 20000 personnes dans
les hôpitaux
c'est comme si au lieu de n'avoir 500
nous autres des hôpitaux on avait 2500
et hier le président macron annoncé qu'à
partir de demain matin
les restaurants les bars les jim vont
être fermées mais y est allé plus loin
que nous tous les commerces qui sont pas
essentiels un peu comme on le fait au
printemps vont être fermés les mesures
qu'on a mises en place sont populeuse au
québec qu'ailleurs d'annoncer la
dernière partie de la phrase qu'il
voulait faire passer comme message
martin il était moins crispé qu'au début
de la semaine
honnêtement ça lui vient donner un coup
de pouce l'annnonce du président macron
y est réputé la semaine était très dur
le y annoncer un prolongement de 28
jours et sous le feu des questions du
des partis d'opposition et il ya un
potentiel
deux récalcitrants là alors il est dans
une situation assez difficile et il peut
il se compare avec plusieurs états à ces
cancres pour essayer de faire passer ces
mesures est là la france va plus loin
alors l'histoire tend à lui donner
raison alors aujourd'hui était dans une
dynamique quand on se regarde on se
désole mais quand on se compare on se
console mouais michèle dawe est
exactement c'est ça oui bien évidemment
monsieur monsieur legault choisi ces
examens il nous a pas parlé de la
norvège ou la nouvelle zélande et je
peux pas m'empêcher de me souvenir qu'à
l'époque où il était dans l'opposition
il eut comparé toujours avec ce kit
meilleurs que nous voyons en italie les
cancres de l'économie en amérique du
nord
maintenant bon je comprends que
maintenant ils premier ministre alors
une compare avec ceux qui sont pires que
nous mais ceci étant dit
c'est vrai besoin des annonces de
monsieur macron depuis depuis une
semaine pratiquement tout le monde qui
regarde la télévision
il voit ce qui se passe en france le
réflexe d'azéma coudes et on n'est pas
si mal ici alors monsieur legault et
c'est vrai on peut pas le nier mais mon
monsieur maquereau dans son malheur
donner un coup de main à monsieur
legault qui m'a dit je pense qu'on
allait l'extrait sûr on y voit un mois à
la fois là c'est dix mois de novembre
s'est fait le test des tesla l'export
écoute au sort je pense que le mois de
novembre est très important pour tester
ce qui va se passer d'un hiver si on est
capable dans la loi de novembre
non seulement de contrôler ce qu'on a
fait on maintenant mais de baisser puis
secret la fameuse marge de manoeuvre
pour nos besoins
moi je pense qu'on va voir tout un beau
succès mais je vous dis là le mois de
novembre deux changements de température
le fait que les gens vont être plus à
l'intérieur c'est vraiment un bon test
pour les québécois dans les prochaines
semaines voilà après octobre novembre
celle ci
oui moi je note que au printemps
monsieur legault faisait littéralement
délit crise avec quelqu'un d'autre
et vous devriez savoir de sa mère est
quelqu'un avec qui comparaît qu'est la
france mais en même temps faut quand
même pas oublier que les vrais
comparable c'est sur les provinces
canadiennes qui ont peut-être même
système de santé puis tout ça et là on
est encore le cas en avril à 60 % des
décès alors qu'on doive 1 3% de la
population
c'est quand même pas très très bon
palmarès mais bon il songera part à la
france et à toute l'europe où loulou
c'est vraiment très virulent comme quoi
des mii on est plus près ce jeu très
bien l'imputabilité ç'avait été noté
qu'il n'y avait pas de patrons dans les
sachets celle des êtres crochet gens
partaient bondés des cas extrêmes bien
sûr mais même dans le milieu ça faisait
dur parce qu'il n'y avait pas de gens
imputables sur place là-dedans on relève
un pdg d' en montérégie
je vous fais entendre monsieur dubé là
dessus qu'on veut en parler
c'est une décision qui relève du pdg de
montérégie centre il ya eu une analyse
de ce qui s'est passé notamment ou au
clsc au ch et celle des pardon de sainte
croix puis cette décision-là s'est fait
dans un contexte effectivement monsieur
la forêt de de responsabilité et
d'imputabilité puis moi je vais
respecter la décision du pdg 25 morts
martin si j'ai les derniers bons
chiffres dans ce ces chats c'est le
dédain montérégie sainte croix alors
voici un exemple on dit bon bien un
patron il n'est plus l'heure parce
qu'ils faisaient pas le travail ça
commence à chauffer l'eau dans les
différents sur ces six des régions on
parle de celui là on peut parler aussi
de celui de lanaudière j'entends aussi
des chaussures un autre dans la région
des laurentides
alors on commence à évaluer le travail
c'est très très inégale seront 10 et le
ministre dubé est sensible à cet été
rappelez-vous que monsieur legault a
placé la barre où il ya dix ans tolère
repos le travail mal fait alors là on
est dans la deuxième vague et on
commence à les évaluer
monsieur legault fait attention à ce
qu'ils disaient mais il ya quand même 10
à mashaal cesser ces histoires de
direction fait pas de café travail on se
met la tête d'un ça encore celui de
lanaudière s'est il était pas au courant
de ce qui se passait avec la communauté
attikamek c'est assez surprenant
ouais bah comme puisque vous en parlez
je vais vous faire entendre l'extrait de
monsieur legault qui répond à une
question en disant oui ça ma chère en
effet il ya le pdg de sézanne aux
indiens qui dit que jamais entendu
parler il fait porter le chapeau à une
ex-employée gestionnaire sa mashaal
d'entendre surdotées ce quand on parle
d'imputabilité sa mashaal d'entendre une
réponse comme ça j'ai rencontré avec
monsieur d'un fresnière je pense au
moins trois fois
le chef au cours des dernières semaines
qui ont été très clairs qui avait perdu
confiance dans la direction il faut
s'assurer qu'on a les bonnes personnes
pour rétablir le lien de confiance avec
la communauté
bon une chaîne abc quand même peut-être
des pas dans la bonne direction si on
peut mettre déjà qu'ils sont imputables
dans ce réseau là c'est tellement
monstrueux réseau ou monstrueux pardon
qu'on doit on doit ramener ça une
échelle humaine
absolument je pense que monsieur leloup
s'en est rendu compte tout de suite avec
les sièges à celle d il ya un problème
souvenirs avec la réforme de monsieur
bart et on a mis 1200 ou quelques cas à
la retraite forcée
alors là il faut aller les chercher
quelque part ces nouveaux cas de là on
peut pas simplement déplacé un bon pour
l'envoyer à notre endroit là où la
personne était précédemment alors je
précommande d'évaluer la qualité de ceux
qui restent mais de toute évidence là il
ya eu une espèce de ménage qui a été
fait et qui certainement privé le réseau
d'excellence éléments maintenant bon
dans ce que si je comprends que monsieur
legault soit soit h allée parce que
c'est vraiment xala deux choses d'abord
de l'agglo qui dit j'étais pas au
courant alors qu' il est clair qu'on
pensait pas dans les recommandations
mais dans le rapport de la commission
vient l'hôpital de joliette est à
pointer du doigt car ceux qui étaient au
courant et deux médecins sur le dos de
noeuds
dame qui n'est plus à l'emploi dessus ce
qui était la protection de la jeunesse
je crois c'est doublement scandaleux le
faisait très bien oui quand même
attention faut faire attention quand
même pour pas couper une tête et avoir
le bouc émissaire ou s'il faut il savoir
un peu aussi ce qui se passe pas mal
dans l'ensemble de la machine et
s'assurer que les correctifs sont bien
bien mises en place pour que le cieux
sous les 6 se redresse parce que des
fois la direction c'est une chose mais
il ya aussi la culture du gros plan oui
très bien monsieur physique est bonne on
va écouter monsieur fait des bonnes
lui-même et monsieur legault sur son
ministre et on revient on parle de la
procédure l'apparence de conflit où
monsieur laperrière était une personne
un ami
il y avait une créance envers moi qui
étais pas significativement temps de
dollars il me présentait des dossiers
alors si je vais refaire l'histoire
j'irai au début c'est très fort
probablement il ya eu d'autres personnes
avec moi peut-être mais en bout de piste
j'accepte commentaires d'or mais à la
base il ya aucune conversation c'est
très important parce que le monde était
et est personnelle et pour monsieur plus
important pour moi
je m'étais questions clés y mettre de
l'argent dans ses poches que des
avantages financiers pour le ministre
l'économie les dunlop sa sauce test
important de comprendre donc je pense
qu'ils étaient totalement de bonne foi
en disant en émoi au sein des projets
est bon je pense que lon ya eu sa leçon
il répondu
ils étaient plus d'un il donne ni qui
est imprudent maintenant il était de
bonne foi et pour moi je tourne la page
voilà à faire tourner michel david alors
frau réaction je peux convaincu que
monsieur seguin mais n'a vraiment
compris parce que quand i 10 août et ce
par manque de jugement
sauf que ok si j'avais eu quelqu'un avec
moi pour rencontrer mon ami ça aurait
été correct non sa propre collègue
l'évocation de rencontrer point à la
ligne
alors monsieur fils ben je comprends que
c'est de vous quand il est arrivé à
didier regarde-moi du projet juin vue
père voyait mai
et c'est pas la première des deux pics
mussy-sur-seine et l'ail et les
incidents de ce genre le soleil ou au
tout début il y avait le problème avec
les cci intérêts acquis qu'ils voulaient
pas classé après ça yeux toute
l'histoire de monsieur leblanc a été
blanchi il a été blanchi mais ça a quand
même traîné dans le paysage à l'état et
là cette histoire alors monsieur
monsieur
les gens de position raison monsieur x
games est le prototype même le gars qui
dit l'homme d'affaires qui s'en vient
pas ici et qui n'a pas compris parce que
dans l'extrait il ne comprend pas
effectivement que c'est le fait que son
ami a eu un accès privilégié aux mines
être rapidement c'est ça qui fait
problème
quelques accrocs trisa rien à voir north
effectivement et je fais du guémon ça il
fait partie de cette génération de prix
etc qui sont arrivés pour français
monsieur gobeil qui amène ce dans le
temps on va ramener les taux comme une
business mais non l'état ça sera encore
comme ça ça fonctionne pas comme ça il
ya des normes il ya des règles il ya des
des garde-fous qui doivent être leurs
parce que c'est l'argent public
et si elle même pas qui a fait des
erreurs de jugement ils ne seront
probablement jamais alors bien sûr son
premier ministre va tourner la page puis
vont voter le rapport en chambre et
touchant ça ne règle pas le problème du
jugement mesure physique est bonne et
disons que si un deuxième pont deuxième
vague de deuxième classe du fond du
classement
c'est ça ça va être autre chose et ça va
devenir assez sérieux martine savard
avait l'air et brûle pas assez dit pied
par dessus la tête il ya lieu d'écouté
j'ai rien fait de mal
il y avait apparence je conviens mais
j'ai rien fait de mal puis il admis j'ai
peut-être était imprudent alors on est
loin monsieur legault a pris une très
bonne décision parce que s'ils avaient
dit je vais y réfléchir
votez pour ou contre l'assemblée
nationale il ya tué cette histoire là
dans l'oeuf en disant oui on va y aller
on va voter en faveur du rapport donc le
respect de l'institution est là et il
est une réprimande le franchement c'est
c'est une mini tâche dans le dos il sait
le nombre effectivement que faire du
chant très près là je vous aime il est
important dans l'entourage de monsieur
legault suffit tribune l'action sont
très près dans leur stratégie économique
l'oeil et imaginer patrice ç'avait été
un ministre libéral qui avait fait ça
pendant que monsieur gouvieux position
samedi
il y en aurait déchiré des chemises et
oui bon parlons de chemises déchirées
bill morneau qui a été blanchi d'une
partie de ce qu'on lui reprochait
michel 6 le commissaire
à l'éthique dit on vous croit que vous
ne saviez pas que vous n'aviez pas
rembourser ses voyages avec la wii
charity la capitale en afrique
le commissaire à l'éthique du québec un
peu plus de mordant quelques misères à
des tic d'ottawa mais c'est à francescas
fédéral les riches sont différents de
vous et moi alors prendra que pour
monsieur mon nokia 5000 $ c'est rien
payer et comme à la première occasion du
rapport il aura en bourse et donc ya pas
de problème bon monsieur blanc sec puis
on n'en fera pas un très bon plan mais
s'il est encore là je pense qu'il y
aurait déjà dans l'opposition qui ça
déchire et chemise quelqu'un qui est
complètement déconnecté de ce que le
canadien moyen peut passer et et peut
vivre et puis ça prouve le genre de deux
ministres des finances condom on s'est
servi de ça contre lui bon maintenant et
puis lorsque d'intérêt un peu
archéologiques la bombe je n'avais d'un
petit mot là dessus
oui monsieur mort nous c'est un autre
récidiviste
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'ils
avaient des problèmes d'éthique
alors monsieur trudeau doit être content
qu'il soit parti
bon martin on surveille quoi demain
après demain est ce que là la
stabilisation il vous reste une mais
deux la stabilisation des cas quand même
fait souffler quand même un peu mieux le
gouvernement oui on sait que le
gouvernement effectivement et plus finit
mieux sa semaine mais il va falloir
surveiller les décès quand même qui
augmente la 25
c'est beaucoup c'est généralement plus
des personnes âgées et c'était quand
même relevé lors du point presse a passé
assez inaperçu mais ce sont les gens à
la maison qui meurent encore les
personnes plus âgées est ce que ces gens
l'ont du service est-ce qu'on peut les
aider
on va voir où sa voix mais je pense que
ça va être le chiffre un peu plus à
surveiller dans les prochains jours très
bien mais oui un petit mot il reste dix
secondes qui voulait parler j'ai entendu
non juste que je comprends que ce soit
nerveux puis quand il nous dit que le
mois de novembre vont être difficiles
mais j'ai l'impression que le
gouvernement aussi on retient son
souffle le cépage pas simplement dans
les familles merci à vous trois à très
bientôt
au revoir au revoir au revoir